[Music]
Orange County California home to Sun
sand
now swing voters the most competitive
congressional races in the country were
held here last year so if you're looking
for a place to find people here might be
swayed by Democrats or Republicans this
is about it good as again and for
breakfast you can't do much better
cappy's cafe right on the Pacific Coast
Highway in Newport Beach it's where we
broke bacon sisters Payton and Sophia
mullet and their friend Taylor Mozart
all college students it's perhaps no
surprise it's on their minds I'm taking
this year off so that I can pay off the
ones I've taken out when candidates
debate one issue grabs their attention
one of the things they've talked to some
of these guys talked about is providing
free college or even forgiving all
student debt realistically I really
don't have a lot of trust
well Mozart the conservative gives
president Trump credit for creating jobs
she wishes his party would do more to
protect the environment what a lot of
people don't want to admit especially
the Conservative Party is when they
admit that climate change is a problem
it becomes their problem to solve I
think it's a really important issue to
think about I was like young people
because this is our world it's their
generation we're going to grow up in it
[Music]
next we headed north the Los Angeles
County so now we've come to what is
essentially deep Blue Bell California
East Los Angeles used to be
predominantly white now overwhelmingly
Latino and immigrant for the past two
decades this community has come to La
Casita mexicana for lunch and so did we
what do you recommend here on the menu
Fernando chilaquiles friends evaldo Lyra
and Richard Rosales don't hold back when
asked about President Trump is that a
novela practically Latinos we watched my
mom we watch novellas it's practically
the same thing it's a novella at the
White House they're ready for a new
chapter in the novella but which
Democratic candidate they pick depends
on the issue of health care all right
got my appendix around on Sunday I have
insurance I had to pay $20 but it made
me think like my mom doesn't have health
insurance he doesn't have health
insurance it's like if they had to go
get their appendix move by an emergency
it's like $50,000 that's something I
feel just be natural
you should be naturally born with
[Music]
so from the beaches and the city and all
that traffic now we've gone world got
into the breadbasket of California
Bakersfield area this is the most
Republican congressional district in the
most democratic state depends
after a full day of driving there's no
better place to fill up the tank and
hotels country diner a Bakersfield
institution for more than tender slice
of tri-tip is no secret here nor is this
group steak on what's happening in
Washington I have taken issue with how
the president is not respected the
position of president is not respected
nothing is ever going to be okay or
accepted in the eyes of the opposing
party tani
Penner's family has farmed around here
for three generations but now she faces
tough decisions we just closed escrow on
selling my dad's farmland the worry of
where we were gonna get our water from
the trade Wars and the tariffs and the
unpredictability of that just is too
much stress if you could tell the
President and whoever he ends up running
against one thing about how to handle
the next year what would it be
stop run it against each other and start
talking about the issues that are
important oh how are you here isn't
bitching about each other stop it and
start talking about how it's gonna
change what they're gonna do for us stop
squabbling in each other you know what
it is everyone sit down
[Music]